in the face of unprecedented Global
headwinds families pensioners businesses
teachers nurses and many others are
worried about the future so today we
deliver a plan to tackle the cost of
living crisis and rebuild our economy
our priorities are stability growth and
public services
we also protect the vulnerable because
to be British is to be compassionate and
this is a compassionate
[Music]
we are not alone in facing these
problems
but today we respond to an international
crisis with British values
we are honest about the challenges
and we are fair in our Solutions yes we
take difficult decisions to tackle
inflation and keep mortgage rates down
but our plan also leads to a shallower
downturn lower energy bills higher
growth and a stronger NHS and education
system
[Applause]
three priorities then today
stability growth and public services
I start with stability
Mr Speaker High inflation is the enemy
of stability it means higher mortgage
rates more expensive food and fuel bills
businesses failing and unemployment
Rising it erodes savings causes
industrial unrest and cuts funding for
public services it hurts the poorest the
most and eats away at the trust upon
which a strong Society is built
the office for Budget responsibility
confirms Global factors are the primary
cause of current inflation
[Applause]
most countries are still dealing with a
Fallout from a once in a century
pandemic
scheme the vaccine rollout and the
response
did our country proud
but they all have to be paid for the
lasting impact on Supply chains has made
Goods more expensive and fueled
inflation and this has been met worsened
by a maid in Russia energy crisis
Putin's war in Ukraine has caused
wholesale gas and electricity prices to
rise to eight times their historic
average
inflation is high here but higher in
Germany the Netherlands and Italy
interest rates have risen here but
faster in the U.S Canada and New Zealand
growth forecasts have fallen here but
Fallen further in Germany the
international monetary fund expect one
third of the world's economy to be in
recession this year or next so the bank
of England which has done an outstanding
job since its independence now has my
wholehearted support in its mission to
defeat inflation and I date today
confirm we will not change its remit
but we need fiscal and monetary policy
to work together
and that means the government and the
bank working in lockstep it means in
particular giving the world confidence
in our ability to pay our debts
British families make sacrifices every
day to live within their means and so
too must their government because the
United Kingdom will always pay its way
I understand I understand the motivation
of my predecessor's mini budget and he
was correct he was correct to identify
growth as a priority
unfunded tax cuts are as risky as
unfunded spending which is why we
reversed the plan measures
as a result
government borrowing has fallen the
pound has strengthened and the obr says
today that the lower interest rates
generated by the government's actions
are already benefiting our economy and
public finances
[Music]
speaker credibility cannot be taken for
granted and yesterday's inflation
figures show we must continue a
Relentless fight to bring it down
including a rock-solid commitment to
rebuild our public finances Richard
Hughes and his team at the obr today lay
out starkly the impact of global
headwinds on the UK economy and I'm
enormously grateful to him and his team
for their thorough work
the obr forecast the UK's inflation rate
to be 9.1 percent this year and 7.4
percent next year
they confirm that our actions today help
inflation to fall sharply from the
middle of next year
they also judge that the UK like other
countries is now in recession
overall this year the economy is still
forecast to grow by 4.2 percent
GDP then Falls in 2023 by 1.4 percent
before Rising by 1.3 percent 2.6 percent
and 2.7 percent in the following three
years
the obr says higher energy prices
explain the majority of the downward
Revision in cumulative growth since
March
they also expect a rise in unemployment
from 3.6 today to 4.9 in 2024 before
falling to 4.1 percent
today's decisions mean that over the
next five years borrowing is more than
halved this year we're forecast to
borrow 7.1 percent of GDP or 177 billion
pounds next year 5.5 percent of GDP or
140 billion pounds then by
2027-28 it falls to 2.4 percent of GDP
or 69 billion pounds as a result
underlying debt as a percentage of GDP
starts to fall from a peak of 97.6 in
2025 6 to 97.3 percent in 2728
I also confirmed two new fiscal rules
the first is that underlying debt Must
Fall as a percentage of GDP by the fifth
year of a rolling five-year period the
second that public sector borrowing over
the same period must be below three
percent of GDP and the plan I'm
announcing today meets both rules
today's statement delivers a
consolidation of 55 billion pounds and
means inflation and interest rates end
up significantly lower
we achieved this Mr Speaker in a
balanced way
in the short term as growth slows and
unemployment Rises we will use fiscal
policy to support the economy the obr
confirmed that because of our plans the
recession is shallower and inflation is
reduced
unemployment is also lower with about 70
000 jobs saved as a result of our
decisions today
then once growth returns we increase the
pace of consolidation to get debt
falling this further reduces the
pressure on the bank to raise interest
rates because as conservatives we do not
leave our debts to the Next Generation
so
early
[Applause]
so Mr Speaker this is a balanced path to
stability tackling inflation to reduce
the cost of living and protect pensioner
savings while supporting the economy on
a path to growth
but it means taking difficult decisions
anyone who says there are easy answers
is not being straight with the British
people some
some argue
some argue for spending cuts
that that would not be compatible with
high quality Public Services
others say savings should be found by
increasing taxes but conservatives know
that high tax economies damage
Enterprise and erode Freedom we want low
taxes and sound money that conservatives
know sound money has to come first
because inflation eats away at the pound
in people's pockets even more
insidiously than taxes
so with just under half of the 55
billion pound consolidation coming from
tax and just over half from spending
this is a balanced plan for stability